practically faux be ashamed to let it go
to waste
besides we leave it here a very drunk
person could find it drink themselves
into even more trouble
and I swore a solemn oath first of all
do no harm you're the medic
recommendation Hey leave some for me
we need to drink fast before they catch
us come on a tide
[Music]
romi to the moon you're dead wrong
Luke it's right there in the middle of
the lake
what are you doing what one usually does
on the moon
[Music]
sorry was it that bad or have you
developed an elegy for me I had too much
to drink
[Music]
awake already for a while now
did you know you've gained 27 new scars
since we last saw each other keeping
count mm-hmm I do that sometimes did we
make it to the moon forgotten already no
not the sort of thing you forget exactly
sound like you wish you could no I
certainly won't forget that and I
definitely don't regret it but I do need
to sort it all out in my head alone
Shawny wait before you go need to ask
you a favor
yes it's about all geared seems a
mysterious man can't escape the
impression his story's more complicated
than I thought could you look into it
see if you can learn something sure be
glad to Thanks
be seeing you yes see you later Geralt
[Music]
you